un trophée chez les seniors le premier
peut il ya na rupert et une coupe de
france avec bourges décroché à seulement
17 ans à bercy
car si c'est une salle c'est une salle
voilà les légendaires et et venir jouer
ici en tant que je me suis beaucoup
venus mais en tant que public et donc là
vraiment bafoue les parcs et parfois et
gagner c'est et c'est juste incroyable
précision qui a son importance la
victoire en finale contre charleville
mézières fut difficile à obtenir
la martiniquaise a dû batailler ça n'a
pas été facile au début on a eu du mal à
se mettre en route mais voilà prendre
tes mi-temps qu'on a su dérouler notre
jeu
voilà on a pris du plaisir et ça a été
tout seul et c'est ça notre identité
certes le club de bourges ne sera pas
champion de france en 2019
mais quelle saison pour rupert elle a su
se faire une place sa place dans l'une
des meilleures équipes d'europe
et cet été il y en avait intégré
l'équipe de france il ya pire comme fin
c'est sûr non c'est pareil c'est aussi
incroyable là dès ma première saison à
17 ans de pouvoir intégrer ce groupe là
et bages et j'ai vraiment hâte voilà de
commencer et enfin c'est un peu un rêve
qui devient réalité donc pressé de voilà
200 m entraîner avec elle et de faire
partie du groupe
67 58 victoires de bourges en finale de
la coupe de france la troisième
d'affilée
mais pour ian à rupert ce n'est que le
début le début d'une carrière très
prometteuse